several strong aftershocks have left
many Alaskans on edge this morning after
powerful back-to-back earthquakes struck
on Friday it happened seven miles
northwest of Anchorage the state's
largest city
the earthquakes measured magnitude seven
and magnitude five point seven building
shook roads collapsed and a tsunami
warning was issued for time despite the
damage no fatalities have been reported
President Trump said the federal
government will spare no expense on the
recovery Carter Evans is in Anchorage
with the latest Carter good morning good
morning this is a highway off-ramp it
just crumbled when the earthquake struck
there were cars on the road at the time
now they're starting to clean up in a
repair effort out here we spoke with
Alaska Governor Bill Walker last night
and he said the state is just beginning
to evaluate the extent of the damage
the earthquake rattled buildings in
Anchorage with tremor so strong they
could be felt up to 350 miles away and
was shaking like forever that scared the
crud out everybody and everybody's
freaking out a little bit
students Dovan heard s to take covers to
quake rocked classrooms and concerns
about structural damage led the
Anchorage School District to cancel
classes through next Tuesday thousands
lost power downed lines were the
expected cause of this church fire and
in our CBS station and Anchorage this is
the newsroom the shaking brought down
parts of the ceiling knocked over
equipment and shattered glass the quake
ripped through major roads across the
region including parts of Alaska scenic
ylenne highway traffic piled up for
miles nobody just just rat out alongside
Governor Bill Walker we were some of the
first to return to his office and
Anchorage since it was evacuated Friday
morning oh wow look at her laughs he was
in one of the buildings elevators at the
time of the quake well first I thought
it was an elevator but then it really
got going and I thought wow this feels
this feels like the big one this feels
like it's like something that could
really do some damage later he surveyed
the damage from above with the Alaska
National Guard Walker told us it brought
back memories of the state's devastating
9.2 magnitude earthquake in 1964 this
your strength of an earthquake that you
can that you can crumble a perfectly
good highway you can you can buckle a
bridge you can I mean it was amazing the
the power behind what we saw this is
earthquake country out here and Governor
Walker believes that strict building
codes saved lives but there is a lot of
infrastructure damage hundreds of gas
leaks are posing a new danger and of
course there's all this road work that
has to be done the governor says it
could take weeks to recover for CBS this
morning Saturday Carter Evans Anchorage